I've been sat here waiting to get this
level for 5 minutes on video and of
course I miss it another task uh really
disappointed myself I missed out on a
dark totem face because I was afking too
hard so 179 oh I might I might try
to do some dks tomorrow I think that's
what we're going to do uh I haven't done
a whole lot of times in this series
where I've gone out of my way to make
money which is a little weird to say
considering I have a 220 mil bank now
and I mean we're like 18 episodes in but
I do have 21,000 or 21,000 2100 glories
which I bought for around 37 mil so I'm
going to go ahead and charge them we do
actually have the correct number in the
GE I'm going to go ahead charge them out
in the Wy uh more so for the chance at
an eternal glory than just the regular
glories you know well before I go to bed
figured I'd go ahead and get a farming
level actually probably two but here's
the first one 62 and somehow Miss 63
farming well ended up doing another hard
clue so middle of the whole Glory thing
we got a little sidetracked but there we
go knew it would happened eventually
when I wasn't paying attention but yeah
we ended up dying out there I dropped a
ton on the ground I don't know how many
I'm going to go back and be able to get
I think I only lost like two or three in
the actual inventory but I'm sure he's
probably camping the ground knowing I
dropped them and the Moment of Truth he
caught me over here I was working on my
other account trying to get everything
done up and uh
oh is he not here he's not oh he's not
here I got I pretty much got him all
back that's 21 I kept four that means he
only got like two oh my yeah I'm a beast
I didn't think that's would actually
work maybe he just didn't have enough
inventory space uh didn't have a looting
bag on him or something of the sorts but
yeah I'm pretty excited about that I
mean honestly that's better than I
thought I was going to go by the way
thank you to shift drop that's the only
reason I was able to get them all out of
my inventory if this was like
regular where I mean like regular old
school where you didn't have ship drop I
would have lost most of that there's no
doubt here we are back again haven't
really recorded a whole lot lately but
as you guys can see in the grand
exchange we finally sold off all of our
amulets of Glory I did subtract two from
the initial amount that I bought because
I think that's how many I lost when I
died um but as you guys can see there I
didn't take a screenshot of that which
I'm pretty disappointed about but as you
guys can see 41.5 mil and I bought them
all for
37.5 37.6 almost so I made 4 mil off
that um also I only I didn't use this
many of them with stamas and anac Carl
teleports I did use about 400k so I
guess 3.6 mil profit but it's still a
ton of profit working on a video but uh
yeah while I was afking grabbed myself
80 fishing so I think that's our first
80 stat of a non combat indeed I I mean
by oh no damn it damn it and time to go
ahead and finish up our dagoth task I
know I said I was going to do dks but my
internet has been terrible so decided to
skip out on that but 320 tasks done and
now time for another one 126 Cal fights
obviously disgusting but I can Canon him
so is it really that bad time for
another task Cal fight's pretty easily
done and quickly done I guess 151 black
demons AFK and the catacombs give me
that totem here we go about to grab a
farming level before I go ahead and do
that test so 64 I think that's the only
level we'll get got another little
donation to the uh the alcoholic fund I
uh I I appreciate it my man lunar bow
and there we go missed it kind of I kind
of got it 82 attack there we go and
there we go black Demon's done I did
only get one piece but that's fine
trolls pretty easy task but since I
don't have uh lunar Isle they're not
lunar Isle done since I don't have fic
Isles done not really worth it fire
Giants whatever I'll do them and here we
go another task finished off the fire
Giants nice and easy 178 aberin specters
oh God no no thank you oh time for
another task hell hounds yes I could do
cus I thought of this because someone
commented on my YouTube
channel oh my God here we go been doing
a little merching uh not a whole lot but
I just kind of found a good margin on an
item unintentionally um I was actually
gearing up to go do cus but then I
realized I may as well get 65 agility
beforehand because that's going to be
efficient um but yeah so here's what
I've kind of been merching it's just
these imbu Hearts I was able to merch
three of them for around
360k each so that's a little over a mill
from these three merchesi was able to
merge this master wand for another 350k
so that's around 1.4 million total in
those
merchesi I didn't accidentally do this
it just G tracker told me that the last
one I bought was for
40.75 and so I figured the next one I
would buy would be around there but uh
however it was not so that means that
there's around 300K margin on these they
buy and sell relatively quickly so we'll
see what we can do okay haven't recorded
a clip in a while but uh here we go
so I waited too long to record this but
as you guys can see the ancestrial Hat I
was able to make 200k on then you guys
are just going to have to go ahead and
trust me on this one I had three
bludgeon merges earlier for 300K each
which brought me up to about a 900k
profit so in total all that 1.1 mil kind
of just working over here with some
money while I H AFK so really don't know
what to merge there's not a lot of great
items right now the ancestrial Hat was
pretty decent I might go back to it all
right not something I do a lot but I'm
going to go ahead and just sell off all
of this junk in my bang as you guys can
see lately I've kind of reorganized
everything and it makes it look kind of
nice except this clue tab I have no
plans on touching this because it looks
disgusting and I don't know what else is
going to come in there in the future but
as you guys can see the Slayer tab's
kind of building up along with the
Skilling tab we have a lot of dehd a lot
of stuff so I'm going to go ahead and
sell it all off and I'll be back in a
second okay so something I wanted to
quickly address people always question
me on why I have these things in my
grand exchange just stuff that's always
sitting here this Arabs hood is just you
know random hopefully someone buys it
one day it was kind of pimped out in a
video that you could buy your own
margins and kind of make cool little
like pictures out of just buying stuff
for really high margins and the example
this guy did in his video was aram's
Hood I think his name is like Michael
something to do with RuneScape you guys
probably know who he is but I figured
I'd shut him out in case you know you
wanted to know who actually talked about
it um on top of that this salt pet or
salt peter or whatever this is I don't
know that's I just don't know how to
pronounce it but basically this is
something to do with dynamite dynamite
is a sort of blast mining thing that you
can do in game so basically my thought
process was these things used to be 500
GP each now with the introduction of
raids and wintert they've dropped all
the way to five but if they ever become
useful in any way and JX tries to bump
up their price again there's really no
way for me to lose money on this and
earlier this month they were at 30 coins
each so just in that month I mean if
they ever go back up I could get six
times my money back so my plan to buy
about a mill of them for 5gp each and
just see where they go and there we go
finished selling off everything that I
could um so right now we have 7.2 mil
plus the 5 mil that's what I got from
selling off in total so that's 12 mil
and I also banked 18 mil earlier on
accident so that's a total of 30 mil
that I got just from selling off random
junk in my bank uh not junk obviously
but stuff that I never would have
utilized so really happy about that I'm
going to find a way to sell off about
another 20 mil and stuff so then I can
merch declaw but right now for some
reason run dards are buying for
967 and just uh an hour ago they were
selling for 1,070 so I'm going to try to
buy as many as I can and make 100 GP off
each one easy money thanks a lot man
thanks a lot shout out God I don't know
how to say his name szy I don't oh god
oh butchered well that was pretty lucky
on my part I just went to class so that
took like three hours but the dragon
claw the dragon claws that I was buying
I was able to merge for 240k there these
ones I was able to sell off right where
I bought them so no no profit made there
and then about another 300K made there
so that's like 500k in total off DE claw
which isn't that great but when you
account for the fact that I bought these
for
125.638 if they didn't sell I was about
to lose a decent amount of money luckily
enough they sold so as you guys can see
here I'm selling all of the ones that I
bought earlier off for a total of 4.44
mil and I bought them all for a little
under 4 mil which means I went ahead and
made 500k off that I pretty much knew
that that was going to be profit because
there's no reason they should have
dropped that much probably just someone
that was merching them went ahead and
dumped them and so making a decent
amount of money off that and here we go
another farming level for the night so
65 getting on up there obviously quick
skill but happy see it progressing here
we are 64 agility got to get 65 so then
I can use the tab really shortcut this
makes me hate myself more than anything
and there we go 65 agility
so I know I started doing agility just a
second ago as far as the video goes that
was yesterday I hate agility with my
heart and soul but all right so one
thing I did do was last night I made 3.5
mil on a merch I just want to go ahead
and add that in right here so you guys
know like where the bank's kind of
standing what I've made money on I'm
just going to go ahead and tell you guys
it's an item that if I gave away it
would never have a margin again so
there's there's no point in me telling
you because you're not going to be able
to profit off of it and it's only going
to hurt me and my money-making ability
on the account so I don't do a whole lot
of agility so this is actually a pretty
big deal to me but going to go ahead
grab myself the graceful top which is
pretty impressive um as far as I'm
concerned it's quite the feat which now
gives us two total pieces which uh proud
of about I I couldn't imagine and here
we are oh my God 94 Mage lot of things
unlocked with this one obviously the two
big ones I maybe the only two Vengeance
and Ice barrage finally unlocked might
go pking here in the future I mean
nothing nothing in my account says that
I can't do that so maybe we'll do that
in the future um but yeah 94 Mage uh I
probably spent about two mil on runes
right now just uh merging
um in the background I also made back
the two Mill with the item that I I'm
sorry but uh yeah so here's all of the
unblessed symbols that we ended up
getting I mean it's 1.5 mil so I guess
it's decent the the guide price is 1.5
mil trust me but I mean it's it's all
right we got a return but lot of money
thrown into that one happy to finally
get it going to stop training Mage now
and first Cerberus kill coming in so
this is a little bit new we haven't seen
any of this
um I'm used to it I've killed like 7 to
800 on my main I haven't gotten any
primordials that's a really good way to
start though that that uh eases up the
rest of my trips or at least like the
next 30 kills or so just getting a
couple kills before I go to class and uh
yeah I mean we hit the we hit the table
I'll take it it's a m drop uh I guess
800k more so little depressed that I
still haven't gotten a primordial on
either account granted I've done like 8
to 900 kills but I'll take it nice
little profit didn't expect another one
of these as quick don't mind all of
these death piles over here but Eternal
crystals so there we go that's a couple
mil too uh I'm upset oh Jesus if that
actually sells off for six mil I'm
really happy I thought it was like three
um one of the things though I'm not I
don't know I've hit the I don't know how
to explain this I I'm I'm spoiled
already having two drops within 50 kills
but I still haven't got a print and I've
hit the the uh table for these combined
on both my accounts like six seven times
now and I'm like just give me a prim man
late night Farm run per usual there we
go 66 farming dieded Cerberus came back
and someone was here he pretty much
extorted me for putting him in the vid
to hop so there you go now I'm just
playing but thanks a lot man and here we
are final kill the Tas so that is a long
while than that took me but one thing I
did learn that I wasn't aware of
whenever I came here I kind of was but I
wasn't at the same time was the fact
that I need to pray Mage while I do this
boss I went the first 75 kills praying
melee I didn't look up a guide I just
went off a memory and I figured melee
was a way to go and then someone's like
why the hell are you praying melee and I
was wondering because on my main I kept
always getting like 8 to 10 kill trips
and I was getting three to four kill
trips and I'm like yeah there's a
defense level there but you wouldn't
think that would make that much of a
difference and uh yeah the trips towards
the end started to get a little better
we we'd average like five to six kills
if we're lucky depending on the drops
that we get but let's go ahead get
another test that was really fun I was
hoping I was get a Primm but I mean I'm
not mad with the stuff that we got and
another boss Tas so kbd here we come
really happy about that actually I love
Slayer for bosses more than just the
actual like grind a lot of things going
on right here um one Spectra went up a
ton I don't have the price of when I
bought it but according to GE tracker I
bought it about two days
ago and with that said it was 4 42 to 43
mil and I was able to sell on for 45.5
so we'll say we made about 3 mil on that
uh on top of that I saw that you can
merch him for about 500k I haven't
merched any yet however I'm going to go
ahead and try I can buy three right now
so that's where we're going to start all
right so naturally as I do um whenever
something good happens something bad
happens in return ended up buying one
spectral Spirit shield for 75500 as you
guys can see went ahead and made another
380k on that so we go ahead and had all
that up from the past we pretty much
made about 1.5 mil and then I was able
to buy another three spectrals and yeah
I sold off one for the same price so
nothing lost there then I sold off
another two for 600k loss on both losing
us 1.2 mil and effectively meaning I've
only made 300K off Spirit Shields little
Annoying uh Den bull work I made 50k off
of an eclectics as you guys can see
there I bought all of these or I sold
all these for almost 12 mil and I bought
them for 11.8 so that's like 200k profit
not a whole lot going on I I mean I wish
the spectrals would have done better but
it is what it is and so with those sad
times coming upon us I think this is
where we are going to have to go ahead
and end off the video as you guys can
see that's probably the most cash I
think we've ever seen in an episode so
148 mil right there all right so we have
to keep in mind the grand exchange
offers as you guys can see 1.9 mil here
um trying to buy these all for five I
can sell all these on for 14 right now
apparently is what they're buying for so
add the 1.9 with the 1.8 you go ahead
and get yourself 3.7 7 mil from there we
will go ahead and price check the bank
and here we are Bank valuator on conduit
not a sponsor just shouting them out
let's go ahead and calculate it
[Music]
so
Jesus 241 mil you go ahead and add on
the 3.8 that we already have in the bank
that means we're up to about 245 which
is an insane amount we are definitely
moving on this account and uh yeah
really excited uh next episode I will
unlock Z I can guarantee it I was going
to do it at the end of this episode but
I just got caught up in some homework
and stuff so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this episode if you guys did make sure
to leave a like um if you guys have
anything you guys want to go ahead and
tell me comment that down below and uh
yeah that said hope you guys have a
wonderful day and
[Music]
d